it's looking more and more like an open
border an illegal immigrant now accused
of killing a mother and son while
driving drunk and he had already been
deported multiple times before his
latest arrest lisaa is live in Denver to
fill in the missing pieces on this story
Lisa good morning hi good morning Bill
four times four times ice officials tell
Fox News they deported the suspect Jose
manavar and if convicted in this deadly
crash it will be his sixth DUI in a bond
hearing yesterday the judge agreed to a
$250,000 cash Bond Witnesses say manavar
was driving about 100 m an hour when he
slammed into the car Melissa Powell and
her 16-year-old son rean were driving
menar is charged with killing them both
toxicology results show his blood
alcohol level was three times the legal
limit ice tells Fox menar is from El
Salvador and was first removed from this
country in 2009 when in the US he has
been in and out of jail bill listen to
this 4 days before the deadly accident
he plad guilty to a previous DUI offense
according to court documents Boulder
County Judge Zachary malanson sentenced
him to probation and work release even
his prosecutors requested a year in jail
in a statement to Fox News the DA's
office says the prosecutor correctly
believed the defendant was a danger to
the community instead the judge ordered
365 days of work release the court
allowed the defendant to wait out of
custody for a bed in the work release
program over our office's objection ice
Telles Fox News their records show quote
the subject has been previously removed
and has no regard for immigration law as
part of its routine operations ice
targets and arrests non-citizens who
commit crimes and other individuals who
have violated our nation's immigration
laws and Bill look at this this is the
Colorado Bureau of Investigations list
of men aar's appearances and his arrests
in addition to DUI reckless driving
there's child abuse and domestic
violence and of course failure to appear
in court wow he is next scheduled to
appear in court on March 12th we will be
following this yeah what a loss that is
too it did not have to be that way Lisa
cunia thank you in Denver Colorado